[Music]
well hello dear fans
friends welcome to our program i'd like
to know
this is a question and answer program
where you send us the questions
we do the research and if there is an
answer we try and find it for you
thank you for joining us i just want to
give you the address
where you can send your questions to us
it is an electronic address
you'll see it on the screen tv at some
tv
dot org once again tv at some tv dot
send us your questions we'll be glad to
put them
in order in the order we receive them
and then
we'll attempt to answer them and i have
with me my good friend
brother james rafferty thank you for
deciding to join secrets unsealed he's
our newest person on board well not
actually the newest
a graphic designer is that that's right
so but we're glad to have you
good to be here it's a real blessing to
have you on our staff praise god and um
we want to begin with the word of prayer
and then after that
i'll ask you the question and you can
run with it all right
all right father just want to thank you
again for this opportunity to open your
word thank you for each viewer thank you
for each question
each honest question and we would look
we're looking for an honest answer we
know your holy spirit can do that for us
we're so thankful you preserve your word
for us and we have the spirit of
prophecy to help us to guide us to
direct us in these last days
so give you this time we give you our
hearts we give you each question answer
them for us we pray in jesus name
amen well we have two questions left
over from last time
so we're going to deal with the
leftovers first okay and uh you know the
way we do with food and
then we are going to go to a couple of
new questions
and i don't know if we'll have time but
we'll see if we get there
so the question is uh james
this is exactly the way it was sent in
we know
when the judgment of the dead begins
based on the bible
so maybe that would be a good place to
begin you know talk a little bit about
when the judgment of the dead begins
and the question continues is it
important to know when the judgment of
the living
begins okay so yeah the judgment of the
dead
begins according to the bible at the end
of the 2300 day prophecy
that prophecy is found in daniel 8 14
after 2 300 days then shall the
sanctuary be cleansed
and that cleansing is synonymous with
the judgment hour
and we see that confirmed in revelation
chapter 10.
we have a little book that's open a
bittersweet experience
and right after that we understand that
to be the millerite movement
they opened the book of daniel they
studied the process the 2300 day
prophecy
they came to 1844 they
thought that the sanctuary to be
cleansed was the earth
they re-examined it and they realized
that it wasn't the earth but it was
actually
a heavenly sanctuary and a transition
from the holy place to the most holy
place
and right after that prophecy in daniel
chapter 10
daniel 11 opens up with this little
phrase
that is sometimes overlooked when we
study the judgment hour when it begins
daniel chapter 11 verse 1 and there was
given unto me
a reed like unto a rod and the angel
stood
saying rise measure the temple of god
and the altar and them that worship
therein and that word measure means to
judge
yes so you've got this coming in the
wake of the millerite movement
which by the way closes with the phrase
verse 11 of revelation
10 and he said unto me thou must
prophesy again before many peoples and
nations and tongues and kings so we know
that wasn't the second coming of jesus
christ there's a message that must go
out and then the message that the first
message that is given
to john that has to go out is a message
of judgment of measuring the temple of
the altar
and then the worship therein so we
understand 1844 to be
to be the beginning of the judgment hour
and it begins with the dead
and we see that in revelation chapter 6
out of the fifth seal
all those who have died or are martyrs
are given white robes white robes are
given to every one of them so we know
that
the judgment of the dead begins with the
judgment of the dead begins in 1844 the
judgment that begins in 1844 begins with
the dead
is it important to know when the
judgment of the living begins
well yes and no no i just want to take
us to great controversy page 490.
in the great controversy page 490 we're
told
soon none know how soon
the judgment will go from the dead to
the living are you familiar with that
quote it looks like you're looking i
have it right here you've got it right
there okay give us the context of that
okay the chapter is on the judgment yes
and uh ellen white wrote solem are the
scenes connected with the closing work
of the atonement
momentous are the interests involved
therein
the judgment is now passing in the
sanctuary above
for many years this work has been in
progress
since 1844. soon
none know how soon it will pass to the
cases of the living
in the awful presence of god the word
awful there means
a scene worthy of awe
in the awful presence of god our lives
are to come up in review
at this time above all others it
behooves every
soul to heed the savior's admonition
watch and pray
for ye know not when the time is
if therefore thou shalt not watch i will
come on thee
as a thief and thou shalt not know what
hour
i will come upon thee so basically
because we don't know the specific
date for the beginning of the judgment
of the living we need to be ready all
the time
and we do have a date for the beginning
of the judgment of the dead
but not for the judgment of the living
exactly
and the reason we don't have for the
judgment of living is because people
would wait till the day before
that's one reason another reason is soon
none know how soon we don't know when
that transition is going to take place
and so we start predicting that kind of
stuff
we can get off you know time setting and
that kind of stuff so
like you said and i i think this is key
in the statement
we're living in a solemn time and it
behooves us to be
ready at all times right to always have
the armor on
ephesians chapter six you know the
helmet of salvation shield of faith
the truth the gospel of peace and have
the sword of the spirit and to be ready
at all times
for occupying the position god wants us
to occupy and then we will be right with
the lord and we'll be ready
whenever that judgment passes from the
dead to the living i think though we can
know
the time frame when the judgment of the
living is either beginning or about to
begin
and the parallel is with what happened
with the millerite movement
in the millwright movement you had the
midnight cry
which was given in july august of 1844.
and the midnight cry was really supposed
to
tell people the hour of god's judgment
is about to come
they misunderstood that it was going to
be the second coming
but really it was an announcement that
people should get ready because
something momentous
was going to happen i believe that when
you study all of the evidence in the
bible
the loud cry will be the equivalent of
the midnight cry
at the end of time that's exactly what i
was thinking yeah fantastic well
you know people who sit at this table
they have their thoughts are on the same
page
but but you know when we see the loud
cry being proclaimed
god's faithful remnant being persecuted
and multitudes coming out of the
apostate churches
and sunday laws and the sunday laws we
know
that the judgment of the living is
either about to begin or has begun
because the sabbath sunday issue is
what's going to separate
the the faithful from the unfaithful
among the living
yes and this is in harmony with what we
just read
because soon none know how soon we don't
know when those things are going to
happen those events
those final events are going to happen
but when they do happen we're told they
will be rapid
so we can't be waiting you know i know
people who are waiting for the sunday
law and then they'll get right with the
lord and then they'll get back to church
and you can't do that because
right the the parable of the of the ten
virgins in matthew 25
tells us it's not enough to just have
your lamps trimmed and burning you've
got to have the oil
so the oil is the character and the
character development takes place
now we prepare now for that time ahead
for that testing and the holy spirit is
the one
the oil represents the holy spirit
working in our lives
on our characters so that we can have a
character similar to the character of
christ
but there's another thing here that that
is really important
you know we talk about preparing for the
close of probation
and of course that's the preparation for
the
corporate close of probation for the
world
but there's another probation that
closes before that
it is the individual close of probation
and that happens when a person dies in
fact the apostle paul says in
hebrews chapter 9 verse 27 as
it is appointed for men to die once
but after this the judgment so in other
words
you know if we don't get to the moment
of the close of probation for the world
but we should die before that right our
probation is closed
that's why captioning not
that's the available clothes yes but you
also have a corporate clothes
so we have to be ready all the time amen
for either or yeah
and it's a good thing to be ready all
the time too always ready it's a good
thing to be
prepared for whatever it is that god is
calling us to be ready and prepared it
brings peace to our hearts to know that
we're right with god we're walking with
god
right you know otherwise you're living
in fear and uncertainty you're not sure
if your name is going to come up you're
not sure
how you stand god wants to do away with
all of that he wants us to be assured he
wants us to be
filled with joy and assurance and happy
in our relationship with him filled with
peace perfect
love casts out fear all of it
don't misquote that now remember we're
on the same page because we're reading
from the same page
i'm just paraphrasing first john 4 19.
perfect okay so the answer to the
question
um we know when the judgment of the dead
begins based on the bible is it
important to know
when the judgment of the living begins i
don't think it's important to know the
specific moment
but it's important to know that we're
moving on to
the time which i believe is going to
take place in our day
you know i'm not predicting or anything
but by all the signs that are taking
place in the world
you know it could very well happen in
our lifetime
so okay well let's go to the next
question okay
the next question is very simple my
question is
what does luke 17 verses 7 through 10
mean all right so if you want to read
that start by reading them yep
all right luke chapter 17
[Music]
through ten but which of you having a
servant plowing or
feeding cattle will say unto him by and
by when he has come from the field go
and sit down to meet
and will not rather say unto him make
ready where with i may sup
and gird thyself and serve me till i
have eaten and drunk and afterward thou
shalt eat and drink
does he thank that servant because he
did the things that were commanded him
i tro not so likewise ye when ye shall
have done
all those things which are commanded you
say we are unprofitable servants
we have done that which is was our duty
to do
you know it's helpful to compare what
other modern versions say
okay because they make it to perhaps a
little bit clearer okay
uh let me just read from a couple of
them uh
in the new century version
uh it says suppose one of you has a
servant who has been plowing the ground
or caring for the sheep
when the servant comes in from working
in the field
would you say come in and sit down to
eat
no you would say to him prepare
something for me to eat
then get yourself ready and serve me
after i finish eating and drinking you
can eat
the servant does not get any special
thanks for doing
what is master commanded it is the same
with you
when you have done everything you are
told to do
you should say we are unworthy servants
we have only done the work we should
and the living bible i like the way the
living bible puts it of course it's a
paraphrase
but it still helps us catch the sense
if your faith were only the size of a
mustard seed jesus answered
it would be large enough to uproot that
mulberry tree
over there and send it hurtling into the
sea
your command would bring immediate
results then it says
when a servant comes in from plowing or
taking care of sheep
he doesn't just sit down and eat but
first prepares his master's meal because
he's a servant right
and serves him his supper before he eats
his own
because he's not the lord he's the
servant right and then it says and he
has not even thanked
why isn't he thanked well because he's
doing what he's supposed to do he's not
even thanked
for he is merely doing what he is
supposed to do just so
if you merely obey me you should not
consider yourselves worthy of praise
for you have simply done
your duty i think that catches the sense
very clearly
of what jesus was trying to teach of
course you began in that one it begins
in verse five it means a little earlier
yeah i think it's really important
because jesus is giving a parable here
in answer to a question and the question
that's being asked in verse 5
is the apostle said unto the lord
increase our faith
and first of all jesus says well you
don't need a lot of faith
you just need the right kind of faith
you know sometimes we think faith is
quantity but it's not it's quality it's
the faith of jesus
that's what we need we need the right
faith and then he tells this story now
the parable that he tells the story that
he tells
is in answer to the question increase
our faith
and the thing that i believe inhibits
our faith many times
as believers as christians this may
sound a little bit off but just follow
me with this
is our works so jesus here
is trying to increase their faith by
diminishing the value of their works
if you know what i'm saying he's trying
to tell them listen
everything you do in commandment keeping
leaves you in a position where you still
need
to be saved by my grace so and that
comes by faith
you know through faith by by grace
you're safe through faith and that not
of yourselves it's the gift of god
not of works lest any man should boast
for we are his workmanship created under
good works but we're not saved by those
works
right that's the point he's making right
here so he tells them listen
let me give you the story if you did
everything i mean you knock yourself out
and then you come
to the house and of course the master
says you know and so you knock yourself
out again
and then the master doesn't even thank
you that's where your works
play in relationships to salvation your
works
that that is the position of your works
in relationship to salvation does that
increase your faith
yeah you know the bottom line is that
true love
is giving without expecting anything in
return amen
that's true love giving up without
expecting anything in return
so if a servant serves his master
because his master he wants it to hear
his master say
well done that's the wrong motivation
for serving the master
right right and so that's the whole
point here
is that uh you know a servant
isn't concerned about getting the credit
or getting the praise
because he's the servant so i think that
basically that's the lesson that's being
taught here yep
okay okay
um ellen white let me just read you a
statement from ellen white here
volume five of the bible commentary
1122.
our acceptance with god is sure only
through his beloved son
and good works are but the result of the
working of his sin pardoning love
they are no credit to us and
we have nothing accorded to us for our
good works
by which we may claim a part in the
salvation of our souls
salvation is god's free gift to the
believer
given to him for christ's sake alone
the troubled soul may find peace through
faith in christ
and his peace will be in proportion to
his faith and trust
he cannot present his good works as a
plea
for the salvation of his soul
unprofitable servant right you've only
done what you're commanded to do
right yeah so that increases our faith
because we're saved by
grace through faith sure yeah yeah good
i think well i think that
we've pretty well answered this question
uh let's go to our next question
uh it's based on revelation chapter 1
and verse 7.
okay revelation 1 verse 7.
uh let me just frame uh the context of
the question so
that uh we we are organized in our
response
okay um we believe as adventist
that the bible teaches and we know the
bible teaches
that there are two resurrections there's
the resurrection of the righteous
at the second coming and there's the
resurrection of the wicked
after the second coming after the
thousand years after the thousand years
after the thousand the second coming in
the thousand years
uh so uh and jesus said you know there's
the resurrection
of the domination and the resurrection
of the just in john 5 and verses 28 and
29.
but um revelation 1 verse 7 appears to
be
the exception
[Music]
because it mentions a group of of
individuals who are wicked
who resurrected the second coming and
not after the thousands and not after
the thousand years so
so you want to read that verse and maybe
we can try and find a response
okay revelation chapter 1 verse 7 behold
he cometh with clouds
that's speaking of the second coming and
every eye shall see him
and they also which pierced him and all
kindreds of the earth shall well because
of him
even so amen so so the question is being
asked here
is what about revelation chapter 1 verse
7.
how does that relate to the first
resurrection and the second resurrection
right right
okay that's that's the question okay
well there are a couple of verses you
want to take a look at these sure uh the
first one that
that comes to mind for me is matthew
chapter 26
verse 64. yes jesus here is
before he's in he's in uh he's in
judgment he's
he's been brought before um pilate
and the sanhedrin uh actually he goes
before
three different judgments uh more than
once he goes before pilate he goes
before the sanhedrin he goes before
herod but in this particular case he's
before the jewish
leaders and in verse 64
he is this is actually his trial
yeah his trial in verse 64 he
is in the context of this he's being
questioned by the high priest
tell us because he's just being silent
tell us
whether or not you are the christ the
son of god and
he's observed by the most high god and
so he's been silent so far but he cannot
remain silent when he's asked in the
name of the lord whether or not he's the
son of god so he responds
and his answer is under oath his
anderson answers
that's what he says that's what it means
when he says i conjure you yes
you know what the answer you're going to
give is under oath okay and so you
better make the right answer because if
you don't
uh that that uh is going to cause you
problems yes and you can't lie
right not that you ever did but there we
go all right so
verse 64 jesus said unto him thou has
said
nevertheless i say unto you hereafter
shall you
see the son of man sitting on the right
hand of power
and coming in the clouds of heaven
so this is a reference to the second
coming of jesus and what jesus is saying
in this verse this is before we get to
revelation what jesus is saying in this
verse is
you you who are crucify me you who are
appears to me you are taking
responsibility
for my death you are going to see me
coming
when i come the second time so basically
he's speaking to caiaphas
yes who was the high priest yes at that
time yes and he's saying to caiaphas
you're going to be alive to see the
second coming
which means that if he's going to be
alive he must resurrect because he died
right
because he's dead yeah so yeah so this
is what we could call a special
resurrection it's a special group of
people
it's not all the wicked and if they're
definitely not the righteous they're
definitely not the just
because they're piercing christ they're
they're the ones that crucified him
but it is a special resurrection based
on the words
of christ and when we can see this also
in the old testament now there's a verse
in the old testament that i think also
ties into this in daniel chapter 12
verse 2. yes it's not as crystal clear
as this one this one is crystal clear
but it's always good to have two or
three witnesses so daniel chapter 12
also talks about what we've been talking
about in the context of our
discussion the time of trouble the close
of probation
and daniel 12 1 is speaking of the time
when
michael shall stand up and that is
another phrase for the close of
probation we could go into detail on
that i don't know if we have enough time
and that great prince which stands for
the children of thy people and there
shall be a time of trouble such as never
was
since there was a nation even at that
same time and at that time
thy people shall be delivered everyone
that should be written in the book which
means that they went through the
investigative judgment before
because their name was retained in the
book yes and the lamb's book of life
revelation 13
talks about that verse 8. and many of
them so here we have the
the the um basic outline of what's
taking place
michael is standing up probation is
closing the time of trouble has come the
seven last plagues are being poured out
so we have all of this leading up to the
next event which is the resurrection
and the resurrection takes place as
jesus returns and many of them that
sleep in the dust of the earth shall
awake
some to everlasting life ah now that is
the resurrection of the just right at
the second coming of jesus
but notice what it goes on to say and
some to everlasting
shame to shame and everlasting contempt
and that is an
intimation of a special resurrection
that is also referred to in matthew
chapter 26 which we just read
and i believe also therefore confirmed
in revelation chapter 1
and i think this is very very clear
because this resurrection takes place at
the very
end of the great tribulation which is
before the millennium right
so very clearly this resurrection takes
place before the millennium
and immediately after or at the end of
the tribulation
so you really have two groups here you
have the group that is delivered
those are the living righteous right and
then you have those
who rest in the dust of the earth those
who are raised to everlasting life
and you have those who are raised to
everlasting contempt and the interesting
thing is that ellen white applies this
verse
to a special resurrection not only of a
group of wicked people
but she also applies it to a special
resurrection of
a righteous group those who died in the
faith of the third angel's message
which the foundational verse is
revelation 14 verse 13
where it says blessed are those
immediately after the three angels
message blessed are those who die
from now on in the lord there's a
special blessing for those who die
after the third angel's message three
angels messages begin to be proclaimed
yes they are resurrected to see christ
come
and they stand with the 144 000 at the
end of time
yeah and if you look at great
controversy ellen white has the
this wonderful sequence of events i mean
she presents it with biblical foundation
uh you know uh the the general
resurrection of the righteous
takes place when jesus is already in the
clouds above the earth
they do not see the entire second coming
of christ
when you look at those pages you'll find
that you have a special resurrection
when the 144 000 are delivered and
they're glorified
at that very moment those who died in
the faith of the third angel's message
resurrect to stand with the 144 000
and then ellen white describes several
events that take place
and then after those events take place
then
the little the little cloud about the
half the size of a man's hand
is seen gets closer and closer and
closer and when jesus is above the earth
in the cloud
he calls the rest of the of the saints
up from the tomb
so the group of righteous people and the
group of wicked people in this verse
is a special resurrection it's not the
general general resurrection of the
righteous or the general resurrection of
the wicked
got it okay so we've got daniel chapter
12 verse two we've got
matthew chapter 26 verse 64 and we've
got revelation chapter one verse seven
any other verses you can think of
i can't think of any specific verses
okay uh other than those
okay but i think that in the um voice of
two or three witnesses every word is
confirmed so we have three
yeah that's right and one of them is
jesus
that's right okay what else do we have
for questions well anyway
i don't think we have time to answer
another question but
let me just mention for next time uh the
question that we're going to
actually deal with is a very interesting
one it has to do
with another special resurrection okay
it has to do with the resurrection
of a certain group of righteous saints
that resurrected when jesus did
and came out of the tomb and went to the
city and witnessed
that christ had resurrected and uh you
know it's kind of a mysterious group
because
you don't have a lot in the bible about
them
there's only one other verse that
alludes to that and that's ephesians 4
verse 8
where it speaks about jesus taking
captivity captive and giving gifts to
men
and that comes from psalm 68 which when
you read that psalm
that's phenomenal yeah it's an amazing
psalm it is so
but we don't have time for that our time
is just about up we want to thank all of
you for joining us for a program i'd
like to know
remember to send us your questions once
again you see it on the screen
tv at some tv dot org may god bless you
and keep you
remain strong in the lord and we hope to
see you next time and i'd like to know
[Music]
you